[Music]
at the same time Spartacus the Thracian
by birth who once served as a soldier
with the Romans but it's since been a
prisoner and sold Frankl a theater and
was in the gladiatorial training school
at Capua persuaded about seventy was
comrades to strike to their own freedom
rather than for the amusement of
spectators
they overcame the guards and ran away
arming themselves with clubs and daggers
that they took from people on the roads
and took refuge on Mount Vesuvius there
many fugitive slaves and even some
Freeman from the fields joined Spartacus
and he plundered the neighboring country
having four subordinate officers two
gladiators named in Emmaus and Crixus as
he divided the plunder impartially he
soon had plenty of men
Varinius Glaber was first sent out
against him and afterwards Publius
Valerius not with regular armies but
with forces picked up in haste and at
random for the Romans did not consider
this war yet but a raid something like
an attack of robbery
they attacked Spartacus and were beaten
Spartacus even captured the horse of
Varinius so narrowly did the very
general of the Romans escape being
captured by a gladiator
after this still greater numbers flocked
to Spartacus till his army numbered
70,000 for the ease he manufactured
weapons and collected equipment whereas
Rome now sent out the consoles with two
legions one of them overcame Crixus with
30,000 men near mount ganas two-thirds
of whom perished together with himself
Spartacus endeavored to make his way
through the Apennines to the Alps and
the Gallic country but one of his
councils anticipated him and hindered
his flight while the other hung upon his
rear he turned upon them one after the
other and beat them in detail they
retreated in confusion in different
directions Spartacus
sacrificed 300 Roman prisoners to the
shade of Crixus and marched on Rome with
120,000 foot having burned all his
useless materials killed all his
prisoners and butchered his pack animals
in order to expedite his movement many
deserters offered themselves to him but
he would not accept them
the consul's again met him in the
country of piscina here there was fought
another great battle and there was -
another great defeat for the Romans
Spartacus changed his intention of
marching on Rome he did not consider
himself ready as yet for that kind of a
fight as his whole force was not
suitably armed for now city had joined
him but only slaves deserters and
riffraff
however he occupied the mountains around
theory and took the city itself he
prohibited the bringing in of gold or
silver by merchants and would not allow
his own men to acquire any but he bought
largely of iron and brass and did not
interfere with those who dealt in those
articles supplied with abundant
materials from this source his men
provided themselves with plenty of arms
and made frequent forays for the
time-being
when they next came to an engagement
with the Romans they were again
victorious and returned laden with
spoils
this war so formidable to the Romans
although ridiculed and despised in the
beginning as being merely the work of
gladiators had now lasted three years
when the election of new prayer tours
came on fear fell upon all and nobody
offered himself as a candidate until
Licinius Crassus a man distinguished
among the Romans for birth and wealth
assumed the Briatore ship and marched
against Spartacus with six new legions
when he arrived at his destination he
received also the two legions of the
consuls whom he decimated by lot for
their bad conduct in several battles
some say the Crassus to having engaged
in battle with his whole army and having
been defeated decimated the whole army
and was not deterred by their numbers
but destroyed about 4,000 of them
whichever way it was when he had once
demonstrated to them that he was more
dangerous to them than the enemy he
overcame immediately 10,000 of the
sparta cons who were encamped somewhere
in a detached position and killed
two-thirds of them he then marched
boldly against Spartacus himself
vanquished him in a brilliant engagement
and pursued his fleeing forces to the
sea where they tried to pass over to
Sicily he overtook them and enclosed
them with a line of circumvallate
consisting of ditch wall and paling
Spartacus tried to break through and
make an incursion into the Samnite
country but Crassus slew about 6,000 of
his men in the morning and as many more
towards evening only three of the Roman
army were killed and seven wounded so
great was the improvement in their
morale inspired by their recent
punishment Spartacus who was expecting a
reinforcement of horses from somewhere
no longer went into battle with his
army but harassed the besiegers by
frequents alleys here and there he fell
upon them unexpectedly and continually
threw bundles of [ __ ] into the ditch
and set them on fire and made their
labor difficult
he also crucify the Roman prisoner in
the space between the two armies to show
his own men
what faked awaited them if they did not
conquer but when the Romans in the city
heard of the siege they thought it would
be disgraceful of this war against
gladiators should be prolonged believing
also that the work still to be done
against Spartacus was great and severe
they ordered up the army of Pompey which
had just arrived from Spain as a
reinforcement
[Music]
our account of this vote Crassus tried
in every way to come to an engagement
with Spartacus so that Pompey might not
reap the glory of the war Spartacus
himself thinking to anticipate Pompey
invited Crassus to come to terms with
him when his proposals were rejected
with scorn he resolved to risk a battle
and as his cavalry had arrived he made a
dash with his whole army through the
lines of the besieging force and pushed
on to Brindisi 'm with Crassus in
pursuit when Spartacus learned the Luke
ulis had just arrived from Brindisi I'm
from his victory over Mithridates he
despaired of everything and brought his
forces which were even then very
numerous - close quarters with Crassus
the battle was long and bloody as might
have been expected with so many
thousands of desperate men Spartacus was
wounded in the thigh with a spear and
sank upon his knee holding his shield in
front of him and contending in this way
against his assailants until he and the
great mass of those with him were
surrounded and slain the Roman loss was
about 1,000 the body of Spartacus was
not found a large number of his men fled
from the battlefield to the mountains
and Crassus followed them thither they
divided themselves in four parts and
continued to fight until they all
perished except six thousand who were
captured and crucified along the whole
road from Capua to Rome
[Music]
you